مرحبا مره جديده يعود الخلاف ما بين
السيرين عبد النور ونادين نجيم الى السطح
ليس خلافا بقدر ما هو امر غير مفهوم سيرين
اللي بدات حياتها الفنيه وعلى عده اتجاهات
منذ ان كانت مراهقه وموجوده قبل نادين من
الوقت الطويل تقبل بان توضع في مقارنه
معها بينما تلتزم نادين الصمت لكنها من
وقت لاخر ترد بتغريده غير مباشره الامر
يتسبب في جدل كبير مع الجمهور والصحافه
لديها راي اخر طبيعه العلاقه بين سيرين
عبد النور والفنانه نادين نجيم زميلتي
بفتخر فيها قلت لها اياها مره على
السوشيال ميديا كتبت له مبروك الميراكلس
زميله اللي بيفتخر فيها بتمنى هي كمان
تكون بتفتخر فيا
هل يمكن ان نعتبر ناديني جيم
المنافس الاقوى اللي يصيرين عبد النور او
العكس هم دايما بيعملوا مقارنه بين بعض
يعني بقولوا سيرين ونادين نادين وسيرين
فاذا صح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بدل الفنان محمد ممدوح من جديد التصوير في
المشرف بعد ان توقف من اجل شهر رمضان
وانشغاله هو وعدد من الابطال الاخرين
بمسلسلاتهم ممدوح اشار الى ان الفيلم
مختلف ومكتوب بشكل جيد يجمع من جديد مع
ثنائيه ناجحه جدا وهي الفنانه امينه خليل
حلو
وبصراحه كمان تجربتي تجربه وليد الحلفاوي
المخرج لما اتكلم معي في الورق يعني عجبت
وجهه وعجبتني طريقه التناول الحكايه حلوه
وحقيقيه قوي
يعني حسناء الموضوع مشكله اجتماعيه جدا
حقيقيه قوي هو ومراته وعائلتين عيلته
وعائلتها
وبيحصل حاجات يعني عتبه الفنانه انوشكا
المخرجين بسبب اسرارهم على وضعها في اطار
فني واحد مؤكده ان ما يحدث ليس بسببها
بسببهم لانهم لا يرونها سوى في هذه
الادوار وادعتهم لاعطائها فرصه مع شخصيات
مختلفه وجديده لافته الى انها تملك
الامكانات لذلك او هم دائما
بيدوني الادوار اللي هي الام
والام الاريستوكرات الشيك وكده انما
الموضوع كده مش مش شرط ان انا بفرد ده او
ده اللي انا بدور عليه بالعكس احب ان انا
اغير
في الادوار بتتعرض علي اتمنى ان المخرجين
يتجراوا شويه يخرجوا عن نمط التقليدي
ببقى محطوطه بعد نجاحها في رسم خط فني خاص
فيها اكدت الفنانه امينه خليل انها لا
تتعمد نوع معين من الاعمال بل يشدها فقط
النص الجيد مؤكده ان الفتره القادمه مليئه
بالمفاجات خاصه في السينما
انا مش مش واخده سكه معينه والله انا بشوف
السكريبت الحلو وبوافق عليه وبعمله يعني
مش مش رسمه مش رسمه خطه والنجاح ده حاجه
دي حاجه بتاعه ربنا يعني انا واحده بحط
مجهود في شغلي وبحب اشتغل مع ناس بيحبوا
شغلهم وبيحطوا فيه مجهود برده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات